"A sixth film in this franchise..."
“They are finally working on a new Final
Destination movie.”
“They basically announced that this is in
the works over at New Line,
another Final Destination movie.”
Final Destination 6.
It’s happening.
But after covering near death experiences
involving a plane crash, highway pile-up,
rollercoaster derail, NASCAR d-sas-tar, and a
bridge collapse, what is in store for the
next installment of Final Destination?
Could fan-favorite character William Bludworth
be involved?
Stay tuned.
"We're toying with having it take place in
the world of first responders: EMTs, firemen
and police,” Perry said.
“These people deal with death on the front
lines every day, and make choices that can
cause people to live or die…
We're thinking that world might be an interesting
way into a Final Destination movie, and one
which can also generate unique set pieces
in a very credible way."
That’s what series producer Craig Perry
had to say about the next Final Destination,
but what I want to know is how this actually
fits into the canon.
As someone who made a 30 minute video where
I basically put everything, the movies, books
and comics into chronological order, I want
to know where this movie takes place.
The lore is important to me.
The danger with coming out with a new installment
after a long gap, is that these tend to reboot
the franchise, which means we’d be starting
over with all new lore.
However, according to an interview series
creator Jeffrey Reddick had with BD, that
will probably not be the case with the new
Final Destination, but it will be set in a
“different world”.
So what does that mean?
A couple of possibilities come to mind.
There’s one scene that has always intrigued
me most about the original Final Destination,
and it’s not that part where Death hides
the evidence of how it took out Tod even though
nothing else like that happens in any of the
other movies.
It’s the part where Clear and Alex sit on
the beach together, look up at the stars,
and wonder what life would be like if the
disasters that impacted both of their lives
had never happened.
ALEX: "You thing they're still up there? Somehow. Flight 180, are they still in flight?
Somewhere, are they safe?"
CLEAR: "I have thought a lot about that somewhere Alex. It exists, that place.
Where my Dad is still safe and I have no idea about this life here.
Where our friends are still in the sky.
Where everyone gets a second chance."
It exists.
A world where Flight 180 landed safely, exists.
What if Final Destination has a split timeline?
I would argue that it already does.
In the original movie, Flight 180 went down
in the year 1999.
But in each of the sequels, the event took
place in 2000.
Sure, this might just be a retcon, but I’ve
come to justify it as two similar timelines,
where most of the events are the same, but
in the sequel universe, everything takes place
a year later.
In fact, the very concept of the series seems
to prove this to be true.
The visions that each protagonist has are
what is supposed to happen, but they make
changes; they alter their destinies to survive.
Each time this happens, they create a new
split in the timeline.
The world where they don’t intervene…
it exists, they just didn’t go down that
path.
The original five are a set.
They go together.
I think there’s no way to avoid the next
movie feeling different given how much time
has passed.
It’s like how you can put an “old photo
filter” on a new photo, but it never feels
quite the same as a picture that was taken
during that era.
So making a new continuity on a new timeline
branch would help alleviate that issue and
prevent the new movie from stepping on the
original five, which could upset fans.
We’ve seen this approach taken with the
Halloween franchise basically becoming a choose-your-own-adventure,
but the idea fits much better with Final Destination
where there’s an in-universe explanation
for it.
But what if I’m taking Jeffrey Reddick’s
word a little too literally?
Maybe when he said it takes place in “a
new world” all he meant was that instead
of taking place in the world of teenagers
and young adults, it takes place
in the world of emergency responders and health
care workers.
Speaking of which, there’s something I have
to do.
🎵 Epic Triumph Music 🎵
If we EVER want to see Final Destination 6,
it’s entirely dependent on ending the COVID-19
pandemic, and it’s becoming clear that the
only way that’s gonna happen, is if the
population gets vaccinated.
I wanted to show my experience so that everyone
knows there’s nothing to be afraid of.
The needle is so small, you don’t even feel
it go in.
I had a little bit of soreness for the next
day or two, but it was never painful.
The night after the second dose I was feverish
and had chills and a headache, but there was
never a moment where I felt scared, because
I knew that this was the vaccine going to
work in my body to protect me, and the vaccine
doesn’t contain the virus.
How it works is the vaccine basically contains
the instructions that teach your body how
to produce the viral proteins that will be
recognized by your immune system.
So if the virus, Sars-Cov-2 enters your system,
your body will already know how to defeat
it, and prevent you from getting COVID-19.
It’s basically your Final Destination vision
that can protect you from disaster, because
without the vaccine, you could become infected,
and nobody can predict how sick you might
get -- it could be mild, severe or life threatening,
not to mention other symptoms that may last
for months or longer.
Don’t worry, I made sure to run that by
a few medical professionals before I said
it out loud on the internet.
I certainly hope the new Final Destination
isn’t about a pandemic though.
I think this era represents a cultural shift
for us.
Horror was super popular from 2014-2018 with
a lot of darker stories like IT, Split and
A Quiet Place, and I can see the genre swinging
back to something more lighthearted, much
how like Grunge was the dark and serious dominant
genre of the 90s, but it got a little too
depressing for people after Kurt Cobain, and
that’s when we started seeing the snot-nosed
pop punk acts blowing up: Blink-182, Sum 41,
Green Day 75.
So I think the time is going to be right for
a Final Destination 6.
They’ve got the perfect writers for it,
Marcus Dunstan and Patrick Melton, the guys
who did Saw 4-7.
What makes Saw such an awesome franchise is
that the later sequels don’t suck that much
for the most part and they even honor the
continuity.
It feels right for these guys to give that
same treatment to the other big 2000s horror
series.
Jeffrey Reddick has insisted that the sixth
is not a reboot, but curiously mentions another
world.
The statement seems to contradict itself.
I’ve explored that the movie might look
like if we take his words literally, but about
if the we them figuratively.
Operating in the world of first responders,
EMT, firemen and police affords an interesting
opportunity, these are all government workers
that might show up the scene of a disaster
and are likely to have interactions with a
medical examiner.
Could we see the return of William Bludworth?
When I made the Horror History episode on
Bludworth, I theorized that he could have
been an escapee of Death’s design.
This character is shrouded in mystery, and
I always thought it would be cool to explore
his past and learn how he came to be so knowledgeable
about how death operates.
I think it would definitely be interesting
to see a prequel, where a young Bludworth
sees the horrors of how his choices affect
people’s lives on the front line, and transitions
to the role of medical examiner so that he
can become an expert on death, namely how
to avoid it.
If you want to hear more about my theory,
click that video on the left and if you love
horror, remember to subscribe to CZsWorld
for new horrors every week, ring the deathbell
and select all notifications and I’ll see
you in the next one.
Assuming we both survive.